all right hello everybody let's see it
looks good
this is grandmaster steven zerk
and i'll be teaching the chess class for
rookies and the chess class for nights
now
let's see everything working well audio
video look good
now so for today i want to recover a few
past games that i think are very
instructive
these first couple games cover one of my
favorite tactical motifs
and this one this game by alaska or sort
of starting at the key position
it's probably the most famous example of
this tactic this attacking
maneuver and we're also going to cover a
subsequent one
so let's see i'll wait a couple more
minutes or wait a minute until there's a
few more people
yeah let's see so today i'm not going to
be playing the people
right now but the next stream will be on
tuesday
all right there we go looks like we've
got a good audience now
thanks steve great name yeah so in this
position again this is a famous game by
alaska
and looking at this position what do we
think where do we think white wants to
play
what might what generally speaking might
want to do in this position
and why
so any ideas
so in this position white really wants
to play on the king side
and it basically comes down to two
reasons
right yvonne's got it
you want to play on the king side
especially a king side attack right
these bishops
are just clamoring to attack on the king
side right they're lined up on the
perfect diagonals
not only that but black's bishops are
nowhere near the king side
so white's got this preponderance of
force aimed towards black's king
the knight and queen are also ready to
jump in
and again black's queen is also just the
lack of black pieces
not only near the king's side but able
to get to the king side right this queen
has no way in this bishop has no way in
this black pawn center is nice but it
also kind of isolates black's pieces
away from their own king
so in this position you are correct
knight h5 is the move
yeah black has yeah black has ideas of
d4 for sure
this bishop and queen lineup can be
strong
but the moment the white is striking
first when we play knight h5
we're creating an immediate threat of
demolishing black's pawn structure with
a capture on f6
and in the game to cover this black
ended up taking white's knight
now maybe a couple of you might have
seen this before this is pretty famous
does anyone know what the attacking idea
is for white here right whether we don't
know whether it's good yet but what
should white consider here
in order to unleash an attack on black
all right so there's the the move that
might immediately jump to mind and it's
pretty logical right recapture the night
you might say well i've got a very
strong attack
and it does look it you know it's not
the least reasonable move in the world
but
when you take here it's a bit too slow
black plays f5
which kills this bishop
and you might play rook f3 next again a
logical move to add fi
add fuel to the fire but now black has
this nice move queen e8
and suddenly you're either trading
queens or if you play queen h3 you're
badly gimping your own attack
so queen takes h5 f5
is a nice defense from black because
like i said not only does it block the
bishop
but now the queen is jumping to the
defense with tempo because the queen
trade would completely kill the attack
so queen takes h5 is logical but okay
it's
nothing special at least at first glance
yeah a couple of you mentioned it
the key here is what actually it's not
just like alaska's double bishops act it
is alaska's double bishop zach bishop
takes each other
and you don't i mean i'm not saying just
play this move i'm not saying it's
automatically good in another similar
position it might be bad
but this is absolutely an idea to
consider just demolishing black's
kingside
queen takes h5 comes with check now
forcing king g8
and now so let me ask you this so
the fact that it's called lasker's
double bishop zach probably gives away
the next move
all right but let me ask you this let's
say white goes rook f3
let's say waiko's rook f3 now and tries
to lift the rook and just do a single
bishop sack
any idea what can black do here how does
black try and defend against this
and this is a good defensive setup to
know
because i've actually seen several games
where white went for this kind of an
attack
and if black responds correctly
it's he actually has a nice way to
escape
right yeah couple people got it yeah so
this is key when you're just attacking
with the queen and rook like this or
just attacking on the h file
f6 is often a nice defense
and this is part of why this f6 defense
right it ruins any
h file checkmates right queen h7 queen
h8 will never checkmate
and this f6 defense is actually part of
why so many king side attacks
involved maybe a knight on g5 or a light
squared bishop that can jump to g6
or even a pawn on g6 could be very
strong something that deals with this f7
route
because in this case there's just
there's
you have to be precise right it's
promising for an attack but
you have to execute carefully
and here white just doesn't actually
white doesn't have much
right
so rook f3 is a little too slow right
you have to check your opponent's
defenses
as well but the key idea is bishop takes
g7
king takes g7 so we've blown the king
wide open but we are down two bishops
so we need to be fast and we need to be
careful
how do we make this attack work here
yeah another line after f6 black is
basically a piece up for
very limited compensation
so yeah this is very important right to
checkmate we're not going to checkmate
with just the queen so we want to bring
the rook in the game
i see some people saying rook f3 to
bring the rook in and i see some people
saying queen g4 first
so let's ask this let's say we go into
the attack right let's say we go rook f3
what might black do
all right good call rook f3 black's king
being on the g file
means that black can actually basically
make an escape
with rook g8
and we're threatening rook g3 king f6
queen g5 mate
but black makes this f8 route
and after check king f8 white does get a
rook
so you get a lot of material back you
have a rook and two pawns
but after king d7 black has a powerful
bishop pair and of course this king is
surrounded by friendly pieces and not
getting checkmated anytime soon
so this is actually another i would say
a thematic defense that's worth knowing
right when the king is stuck on the open
king side one way or another the king
wants to get out of the kingside the
king wants to get over here
maybe it can try through f6 maybe you
can try with the f6 lines i mentioned
earlier
in this case it runs through f8 and we
can get a rook
but if we want if we we should look for
something better
and the key here and this is a nice
in-between move we throw in queen g4
so black can't go king f6 this is
important king f6 he gets checkmated
and so black has to go to the h file
all right this is a good sign king's not
running to the file anytime soon
now and now white goes rook f3
so what is the only move for black here
what does black have to do to avoid
checkmate
and as a little bonus can you read that
read ahead to the next few moves
try and read ahead a few moves in the
future and
give an evaluation of the position
well so rook h3 is coming bishop h4
stalls but it doesn't stop the mate
right
that's just a a useless intermezzo
right a few people got it e5 only way
for black to stop the checkmate i mean
bishop g5 queen takes again
just stalls a move but e5
so now rook checks queen h6
so black has to give up the queen but at
the moment black does have
right even if we if we win the queen
black does have a rook in two bishops
for a queen and two pawns it's not
terrible
this is why you have to keep calculating
as a general rule
when you're reading out a continuation
like this
you want to try and read out until
everything is resolved until
it's not always possible but when
possible when you're reading out a
combination like this
until the position is stable and you can
say okay well this is the material
balance
this is how i evaluate the position
so queen f5 king g7
what's the follow-up to that right queen
of five you have to see black keeps
defending the queen
how would white continue from there
right so i see some people touching on
it you can
you can throw in queen f5 if you want it
actually doesn't change anything
right now you want to take the queen
queen e5 queen f6
is inadvisable
but now white has tate's takes and
whether or not you play queen f5 now you
play queen d song
and you've got this fork of the bishops
which means that whites wins one of
these pieces back
and the game white white didn't bother
with queen f5 but i took in queen d7
white one the b7 bishop and this is what
i mean now the position
has stabilized and in favor of way right
we can say that
white has queen in two pawns for rick
and bishop
even a queen against rook and bishop
without the pawns is often a winning
advantage
and besides white's two extra pawns
black has more pawns hanging black's
king is unsafe
at this point white has a comfortably
winning advantage
yeah i mean don't get me wrong
calculating this is tough
but you want to calc the general point
is you want to calculate as best you can
like that's the ideal but at this point
you don't need to calculate any more
here
that's also what i'm saying there's this
cutoff when you get to a position like
this
you can say okay i don't need to read i
have more moopsie or whites
clearly winning she thinks the material
advantage even before you take the
monster queen and unsafe king into
account
like this is this is where you cut off
your calculation
yeah this is a very nice combination by
alaska
and sure enough i mean takes here and
white one pretty comfortably from here
so again this is only one of many
attacking ideas
but this is a good pattern to know and
again it doesn't automatically mean it's
good but
the first step in playing a combination
like this is knowing
that this is an idea
so now we're going to see this idea in
action
it's kind of it's an extreme gift you
can almost call it a double greek gift
with two bishops and of course
this combination itself is quite
advanced but
the general idea is more what i carry on
yeah we did just see it in action we're
going to see it in action again
yeah this next game another famous game
and what if you haven't seen before
it's definitely worth remembering so
this is a game between nimzomic
and teresh we had a couple decades after
the last one actually
and jumping through this game
so they play an opening setup that was
pretty standard at the time
if these face off of pawns it's a pretty
logical development
but especially back then this game was
in 1914
it was very typical they would just
develop their pieces to pretty logical
squares but
not always in the best way we've
definitely made some opening progress
and it's we're going to see actually a
couple things that could be improved
that i think are pretty instructive
so in this position white plays bishop
d3
and again not some a reasonable
developing move
but one downside is when this bishop is
developed like this
when this bishop is developed like this
black can take
black can settle this tension in the
center and force white to take here
and you'll actually see a lot of games
like this
where one side loses a tempo like this
because this bishops move twice to get
from f1 to c4
yeah it's a handy tempo and so if black
plays a6 here
if you see this position
um it's well this this move with bishop
d3 is not played so much now for this
reason
in this position nowadays the move that
jumps to mind for me here is knight c3
or to avoid losing this tempo in the
future you can take on d5
and actually there are some other games
from that time where knight c3 was
played
but just to show you after bishop d3 if
black takes and plays a6
look at this position and now
if we go into another line this line
with knight f6 c4
tapes and this is the line of the qga
that is popular nowadays this is
actually something i play myself as
both white and black e3 e6 takes c5
castles a6
so this is a very popular opening line
nowadays this position is played all the
time
compare this position to this position
where black's just played a6
and what do you see
right compared contrasting these
all right tempo difference right in this
line
the bishop went straight from f1 to c4
and white's gotten a free move to castle
in this line after bishop d3 takes takes
an a6
white's made six moves in both cases but
this time
this move has just kind of disappeared
right white's played bishop d3 then
bishop takes c4
so that's the downside to this setup
in the game black doesn't take on c4
black makes perfectly reasonable
development
but this is kind of what i'm talking
about especially back then they just
kind of
i mean they developed their pieces and
controlled the center wall which is
logical but they didn't always
do it in the ideal way
yeah the qga is a good way to do it the
more general thing i would say is
if you're going to do a setup like this
at some point for example you might take
on d5 and play bishop d5 check
generally speaking playing e3 like this
passively before black is taken
right is not the strongest i mean i
don't want to act like it's a disaster
you know it's not like white's it's not
like white's in really bad shape or
anything here
but it's just it's a more useful concept
to be aware of
this idea of losing tempe this way or
gaining tempe
because back then they back then again
they just kind of developed their pieces
they didn't really think about exact
move orders and such
yeah taking on d5 and bishop b5 for
example is another thing you could do
to avoid this little problem
funnily enough actually after white
castles black does the same thing
so ironically they both kind of offered
this tempe to each other
and if i were playing i would say that
in this position black should actually
just avoid this by
you can even play a6 when you're up a
tempo
or just take and then develop
right one way or another like this is
also this is another qga position where
black's just gotten a free move right
because this bishop's move twice
so again it's a pretty small thing but
it's a good thing to be aware of right
you don't want to move your pieces twice
in the opening as a general rule
if you can make your opponent do it well
that's also nice
so black develops though and both sides
complete their development
and we end up seeing pretty symmetrical
structures
so why a6 oh so why a6 back
well so back in these positions
um a6 very often it's another way to
gain tempe black will often play b5 and
bishop b7
that's the basic idea of a6 is to
control b5 which has several uses
and fianchettoing this bishop is the
most obvious one
yeah so it's to get this bishop out with
tempo very often
in this case right here a6 isn't so
useful
because right here here if you take on
c4 white will probably take back with
the pawn
and this b5 doesn't come into play
so instead of going for that a6 b5 black
just plays b6
yeah and anti-fraud that's so that's
absolutely an idea
very often in these positions
yeah very often in these positions you
want to play e4 or black might want to
play e5
at the right time because
i mean here black probably won't take on
e4 but let's say black does
just saying it black takes here
now white has a little more space he's
claimed some space in the center is
bishop's a little better
generally speaking if you can pull off
e4 like this well that is definitely a
good idea
and how you prepare it exactly varies
from position to position
incidentally let's say as a little
puzzle
if white goes e4
at the moment it's defended twice and
attack twice so at the moment e4 is safe
do we see a way to uncover another
attacker on e4 for black
why can't white play this here how does
black add more pressure to e4 with tempo
right knight b4
yep people got it so this
right double purpose move it uncovers
the bishop
suddenly we've got three to two on the
e4 pawn
and not only that but we're targeting
this bishop at the same time
and now white's got some problems
so useful double purpose move so it does
allow e5
this does fork the pieces but we're
taking d3
and you do want to check this but the
complications work out for black because
this bishop is hanging too
what about bishop b1 so here bishop b1
is probably the best move
but now for instance the simplest way
black can take e4
see what it take with actually i would
be tempted to take with the knight
because now after takes takes white has
no knight g5 thanks to my queen
but white white needs to play bishop b1
but the point is this is good for black
because now black rules e4 not white
i mean worst case even if white does get
this pawn back
and that's far easier said than done
that's nothing but getting material
equality
so e4 is what something white wants to
do it's just that concretely this knight
before double threat
makes it impossible
so white goes rook c1
this move it might seem it might be hard
to see the value of it at first
but there's a couple ideas behind it
first of all this bishop will likely go
to b1
right to deal with knight b4 threats
maybe to set up a battery on h7
and then it won't be blocking the rook
secondly at some point these pawns will
trade
and then this rook can be very useful on
the c file
so right now there's no open files so
there's no dream squares for rooks
but yes exactly yeah dr chainsaw um
this these files the c d and e files
right because these are the pawns that
are getting traded
these are the ones that tend to open at
some point you know depending on whether
white plays e4
whether these pawns capture these pawns
capture the rooks generally belong on
these files in these positions
is a3 instead of rxe1 an option
it's a useful move it does feel a little
slow to me
but it's definitely a useful move
preventing knight before and potentially
setting up e4 in the future
but that is stopping knight before
definitely has value
instinctively i'd rather bring pieces
out though
so rook c1 and again rookie one i would
also consider reasonable
it's a rook c1 queen e7
and now one minor thing here
the setups here for white and black
are almost completely symmetrical right
bishops are the same these knights are
the same the pawn structure is the exact
same
the one difference is these knights
so let me ask this generally speaking
the knight on
c6 or c3 is more active right this
knight looks a little passive
so trying to un let's try and understand
why did i put the knight on d2
what is this knight being here instead
of here how does it help white
right it opens up this bishop or more
specifically it doesn't block the bishop
we kind of saw that here when white
tried e4
we immediately went knight before to
open this bishop
yeah so this knight it leaves this
bishop open
another thing i really like about it is
that with this bishop being here
so let's actually show after rook c1
queen e7 since this bishop is open
it also means white has this move knight
e5
all right if this knight were here e5
would be hanging because the bishop
would be blocked
but white can use this really valuable
e5 square
and not only that but this knight is
ideally situated to head to f3 at some
point
and reinforce the e5 square
i mean it's very valuable a rook's worth
a rook i mean the exchange is a lot of
material i wouldn't say e5 is that good
but it's very nice it's a square white
should definitely use
so this i would say would be a logical
way for white to use these knights
in the game though white starts to go a
little wrong
a counter attack with knight b4 so
after knight b4 this is kind of the
value of rook c1
the bishop jumps back to b1 it might
feel like it's a little passive here but
it's actually the opposite the bishop
being such a long range piece
means this bishop can do a lot of work
from all the way back here
and at some point this a3 idea that was
mentioned will kick the knight back
so it's okay with this now that's okay
with putting the bishop back here
right the bishop reaches all the way
across the board it does the same things
basically
on b1 that it was doing on d3
now you can already kind of see right
the potential for the bishop attacks on
both sides
if the position opens up
in the game though instead of this
knight e5 which is what i would like
white takes on d5
and nimsovich had an idea here which has
some merit so his idea was after tate's
black takes with the pawn
and now so e5 is actually covered by the
queen now
e5 is no longer safe but nimzovich's
idea was this the plate knight h4
and the thinking is he wants to play
knight f5
quite possibly trade for this bishop
which will leave white with very nice
dark square control
and f5 is not easy to cover
so teresh actually goes
and this is probably what nimzovich
wanted it feels a little weakening and
it is
his thinking is okay well this diagonal
somewhat weakened
so he's gotten he's induced this
diagonal weakness
but at the same time with knight h4 and
sorry with knight h4 and c takes d5
maybe we can ask what has black gained
in the last couple moves
like why is this and this not ideal
he's gained a terrible bishop on b7
for the moment
there are i mean there are cases where
this capture is good
quite a few of them and actually exactly
when to do it is a very tricky question
in chess so don't
think it's bad as a rule because of this
example
the yeah the big thing though yeah he is
off siding that's how i would put it
right
night on the rim is dim now that knight
f5 is taken away
you've you've induced this weakness but
the knight is very silly now
yeah bishop takes h2 is already a
concern in some lines
and actually white decides to solve the
problem immediately with knight f3
so white's basically just spent two
moves going back and forth
the other thing and this is more minor
but the other thing is when doing this
trade
this e5 score i mentioned was so nice
for a white knight
right now it's covered now black has
three defenders and white is not going
to use it for a long time
if ever
so white to set up this week in diagonal
has kind of given black some control
black goes rook d8
well the other problem is now right i
mentioned this knight wants to come to
e5 and this knight to f3
but now this knight can't come to e5 and
this knight's just kind of staring at
its own
at its body in the way here so it's kind
of tough for white to use these pieces
so nimzovich tapes and black takes
right so he's opened up this bishop
and he's created this weakness i
mentioned but
at the same time thanks to these pawns
on the fourth rank this pair of pawns
these are actually called hanging pawns
a very common bond structure
it can be a little weak but
they give black so much room now you can
see black has a serious space advantage
here
and a bit of a development advantage too
right white's queen is still on the
first rank
so numezovic had a lot of phenomenal
positional ideas his book my system
it's a great work on them but one thing
that got him in trouble sometimes
against other top players was a lack of
respect for time i would say
like he he's he's created this weakness
but he's
gone a little slowly and he's given
black a lot of room and as we're going
to see
it hasn't happened yet but given black a
lot of active play
you could do rookie one knight f1
that's actually that's the problem
that's about as good as you can get for
this knight
another handy trick to keep in mind is
having a pawn three squares in front of
a knight like this
right d2 to d5 is actually really bad
for the knight
right this pawn is taking away the two
most active squares this knight could go
to
so that in particular then write f3 is
out of the question
it's taken by the other knight b3 is out
of the question
this knight has nowhere active to go
suddenly white kind of wishes it were
here
like blacks
okay rookie one knight f1 is about as
good as i can see
but then even black can even use this e4
square as we're going to see in the game
in the game instead white goes for
bishop b5
a3 is not a bad idea here either knight
b4 is a concern
at some point b4 would be nice
in black black's going to have some
things to say right black has a lot to
say right now about you playing b4
but if you can play it to target these
bonds by all means
white goes bishop b5 white has the space
disadvantage
so there's some logic behind trading
pieces
but we're gonna see why this is actually
very dangerous
so teresh goes 94
and actually my last play the people i
kind of talked about this sum too
with these active center pawns black has
many more squares
if white had space if white's queen were
active
right if white's queen could get on this
diagonal it would just be checkmate
queen h8 or queen g7
but right now white just doesn't have
room there's no way to do it
actually the only way white could do
that the only way i could do that is by
bishop a1 and bringing the queen to b2
but as you might imagine that's a little
slow
so in the game white trades on c6
and plays queen c2
and so perhaps here actually
perhaps here nemisovich had the idea of
trading on e4
and then playing queen c3 right and
trying to use this diagonal
the thing you put so much work into
weakening
the blacks got black's got the initial
we'll see if black has the initiative
and black strikes first
so black takes on d2
white takes back with the knight
perhaps white should have taken with the
queen to keep more defense around the
kingside
but maybe you can someone see here how
does black create some weakness around
white's king here
how does white how does black
shall we say unleash some pressure
right d4 we've got this unopposed light
square bishop
we've got it on the biggest diagonal on
the board aimed right at white's king
let's use it
so black plays d4 and first of all we
have this threat of bishop takes f3
just ripping apart white's king's
defenses and it's honestly not easy to
deal with
you know white has perhaps a counter
idea of knight takes d4
but as we're going to see we're going to
kind of get into it later
black has some big threats against
white's king in response to that
yeah anytime you have these bonds
especially a bishop like this like i
said a bishop like this
any time you have it d4 should be in
your repertoire right
it's not always good but it's something
white always has to worry about
you know even if white is preventing d4
then white has to basically be on the
defensive white has to make concessions
to be ready for it
and when white plays knight takes d2
what do you guys think yeah i think a
couple of you are already guessing where
this is heading
based on the last game
how do what do you think the next step
is here all right we've got this
beautiful bishop pair
on great diagonals
we've got a white king that has far too
little defense
how do we use these bishops
so you guys so bishop takes h2 these
sacks on the king side are the idea
yeah we do want to prepare it a bit the
same way right d4
so this is a very dangerous threat but
we do need this bishop as well
so white takes on d4 right if he doesn't
take on d4
it's honestly tough to come up with a
good move for white's kingside
let's see so e4 is an idea
the e4 would be a good defensive try
i'm even thinking about f5 at the right
time to try and tear the spawn open
to tear open this defense e4 is a good
idea though i like
e4 is a good principle defensive try and
honestly that's what white should have
played
if white saw what was coming
that's the direction i would say white
should go
let's see f5 so f3 here
now now this is weak though now queen h4
looks very strong
g3 i can look at sacking the bishop
oh yeah f3 immediately right again white
would like to do it to cover this but
then e3
but i do i like e4 better than what was
as a it's a definitely a better
defensive try than what was played in
the game right
we've got this unopposed monster like
squared bishop so let's try and set up a
defense
this is good defense in the game though
white made things a little easier white
took on d4
all right now for those of you who are
here at the beginning what's the
combination
how are we attacking this kingside
right bishop h2 to start things off
very nice white tapes
sometimes declining is a thing but after
king h1 queen h4
the attack's even stronger
queen h4 right
king g1
bishop takes g2
very nice so now if white takes
if white decides to accept both bishops
a couple of you already mentioning the
attacking style it's actually
very similar to the last game exact same
kind of rook lift
first we do queen g4 we force the king
all the way to this terrible h file
and now after rook d5
right but now this yeah it's it's a lot
easier right when you've seen the idea
already
but that's a big part of chess right you
have these attacking ideas
like some of you mentioned the greek
gift where you sack a bishop
and play knight g4 check that's another
common attacking motif
this is also one that's good to know
this double bishop sack right you
completely devastate the king's shield
so rook d5 but hang on in this position
we do have to be a little careful white
has one defense
one defense against mate can anyone see
it
i'll just wait stop at least check me
right i mean there's a couple stalin
moves like queen g6 but the only move
that
deals with the mate threat is queen
takes c5
so yeah this is actually this is a nice
defensive resource this is some cover
defense from white
here though rook h5 is not mate we can
win white's queen
but maybe now what's the best move order
what's the best way to win the most
material here
and again ironically it's a lot like the
lasker game again
all right it loses the queen but keep in
mind
rook bishop and knight for queen is not
such a bad deal
so let's see if we can't get a little
more
and a couple of you are touching on it
right
there's a couple ways but this knight is
hanging
and no surprise when there's a wide open
king when the queen against the white
wide open king a lot of time there's
some useful checks
yeah there's a couple ways to win it but
the gist of it is
we're not just winning the queen we're
winning the night
we check with the queen snap off we snap
off white's queen and next we get
white's knight
with a winning advantage right queen for
rook and bishop
plus white's unsafe king adds up to
a very big advantage for black
and this just illustrates another rule
that the tactics just tend to work out
for the person with the better position
for the person with
fewer weaknesses right this king being
wide open
and this knight being loose
cause serious problems is their benefit
merit to playing rook d8
i don't it doesn't root doesn't feel
like it adds that much
that's the problem because it's not
generating any new threats right
if you do rook takes white does rook
takes and you can't bring the other rook
in
so it feels a little slow
now so this queen f4 check is nice and
black would win
yeah knight d2 definitely has not worked
out for white this game
i kind of mentioned this knight would
have been good to go to f3 and e5
as it was in the game but white did not
play around that correctly
white absolutely did not make use of
that in the game
so when black takes on g2 threaten queen
h1 checkmate
so king takes g2 we covered white has
one other defensive idea here
actually that we kind of talked about
before too
how else can white stop checkmate here
right f3 and this is a common defensive
idea
in the alaska game we looked at f6 from
black for similar reasons
the idea is just to give the king this
square
so queen h1 king f2
i mean even if black even just taking on
f1 is good for black but it's not the
most black indent
so instead of taking immediately first
of all if black tries to be too clever
what if black goes queen g3 here
trying to mate this way
how does white cover this
all right 94 and this is a tragedy
queen's hanging and suddenly we're
uncorking white's queen
yeah uncork's a double threat and
suddenly black's completely busted
because he's losing the bishop
so instead of that yeah and good call
chess thinker
and instead of taking black just
reinforces with rookie eight
planning to add the rook into the attack
so now rookie 2 is a huge threat right
covering the king's escape defending the
bishop
and setting up queen h1 checkmate next
so white plays 94 in order to block the
rook
and a very logical move now black goes
for check
and takes
so black decides to take the rook and
now why is
why is this better here why can't white
take back
right the knight's actually funnily
enough this is the one time
the knight was doing something useful on
d2 queen h2
skewers the queen
and white can resign
so this rook is overloaded it needs to
guard the queen
so it can't take the bishop
what about knight g3 instead it's an
idea it would be good to win the bishop
but now we see the power of rookie eight
right the rook's cutting off the king's
escape and queen g2 is checkmate
i mean the truth is i wish i could
suggest something good for whites
but there's nothing here so white
actually goes for what i'd say is as
good a try as any white goes for d5
and practically speaking right
practically speaking
objectively black's gotten the extra
material and white's facing a vicious
attack
so white decides to go for counter play
on this diagonal and
with queen c3 is an idea
and if you're facing an attack like this
right rather than just kind of roll over
and get a hopeless position
i'd say if the alternate if that's the
only other choice then you should
definitely go for something like this
create some threats
you can play knight f6 the problem is
let's say black just goes to h8
if you take black checks
and put takes on e8 with check and
you're just facing a huge attack
like the king is actually going to get
mated
you just can't afford to take this
knight out of the defense so white goes
d5
here there are several good
continuations for black
yeah queen g2 and f5 is also good
right queen checks king goes up
f5 pins the knight
yeah this is absolutely a good
continuation
you do have to watch out for queen c3 so
the game's not over yet
we're actually going to see this exact
position come up so
so black plays f5 first
yeah there's the kind of the same thing
here
if white checks and takes the rook
well it gets back the exchange but after
check
and takes with check this king is just
not long for the world
you know something like king f4 g5 and
as a general rule if your king's being
forced to a square like this
it's going to get mated
so black could take and rook g8
so white can win back the exchange but
getting rid of this knight it just ends
like this
yeah there's and there's a whole bunch
of winning continuations i'm not going
to go through all of them in depth
suffice to say black's attack is
monstrously strong
so black goes f5 white goes queen c3
creating some counter threats
so now black has to be fast there's no
time to take the knight this threat's
actually pretty serious
but teresh as we're going to see came up
with a nice finish
queen g2 check if kingi won queen e2 is
mate
so it has to go king e3
rook takes e4 f takes
and here it's a little puzzle what is
the fastest checkmate
black to play and mate in three
and a good general rule for looking for
mates look at the most forcing moves you
have so the most forcing checks
that really restrict white's options
f4 is winning it's actually what was
played in the game but after king takes
check
the king actually does some running
there is this there is a faster way
now there right when there's a king like
this as as might be expected there are
many ways for black to win
but there's a forcing checkmate that
leaves white no options
yeah so i think you're touching on it
myro so
queen g3 there we go couple people have
it yeah queen g3 check
covers these escapes only move is king
d2
queen f2 check covers this escape only
move is king d1
and queen e2 checkmate
so that was actually the fastest and
most forcing checkmate
but there are other winning moves too
and it's actually
it's speculated that teresh did this one
on purpose because it's a fancier
checkmate
even though it takes longer to mate
like i said when your opponent has this
much material
a king that walks up here
it's just it does not have a bright
future
queen h2 king e6
check king d7
and one last move black to play and mate
yeah so we've chased the white king all
the way to d7
right this king's gotten some serious
exercise
all right these are the squares we need
to cover
and there it is bishop b5 checkmates
like i said it's speculated he did this
check made on purpose for style points
which which i don't generally recommend
you definitely want to be careful but
sure enough it is mate and it's no
surprise right you have a king on d7
with no defenses
yeah everything's covered
that is true i'm sure it does not help
the game this game's fame i'm sure is
not hurt by
the fact that he went for this checkmate
incidentally another chess term you guys
might like to know
this is called a perfect mate because
every square black needs to cover for
checkmate
is defended exactly once
so that's an aesthetic aspect of this
checkmate as well
hi skye so i'm not playing the people
today
but if you come by tuesday at 3 30
central
then you can absolutely play me
yeah so that's the game right
cherish taking a book taking a page out
of laska's book
and twinning in style so i hope that was
an interesting game guys
let me know if you have any thoughts
comments on it
i'm going to pause for a couple minutes
and then i will come back for the
night's class
yeah thank you all for watching